el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden calificó de brutales los ataques
de Rusia contra zonas civiles de Ucrania
como respuesta a la explosión en el
puente de crimea desde el lunes las
fuerzas de Moscú han escalado su
ofensiva con más de 100 lanzamientos de
misiles que han matado a más de 20
personas
el sindicato cgt aseguró que llevará
ante la justicia la medida del gobierno
francés que obliga a los trabajadores en
paro a volver al trabajo la huelga de
los empleados de la refinerías ha
causado un gran desabastecimiento de
combustible
hoy el 12 de octubre se conmemora en
gran parte de América y en España la
llegada de Cristóbal Colón al continente
americano una llegada que dio pie a la
colonización española del continente por
lo que celebrar la fecha es motivo de ma
entre gran parte de la población que
recuerda el genocidio de los pueblos
indígenas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masdeu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
porque Rusia escaló su ofensiva desde el
lunes las fuerzas de Moscú han atacado
el territorio ucraniano con más de 100
misiles que han matado más de 20
personas y han herido decenas de civiles
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
aseguró que los bombardeos son una
respuesta la explosión del sábado en el
puente de crimea un incidente que el
kremlin calificó de acto de terrorismo
ucraniano en territorio ruso Estados
Unidos ha vuelto a condenar los ataques
de Rusia escuchemos las palabras del
Secretario de Defensa
El ruido de sables nuclea de Putin es
Temerario e irresponsable no esperamos
Ver y escuchar este tipo de
comportamiento de una gran potencia
nuclear eso es muy peligroso y han
escuchado a varios líderes de todo el
mundo enfatizar eso Ustedes deben saber
y yo sé que nos tomamos esto muy en
serio Y esto es algo en lo que seguimos
centrados
y Seguimos observando indicadores
indicaciones y cualquier tipo de
advertencia de que puede haber tomado la
decisión de ir en una dirección
diferente
[Música]
y previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez quien nos analizó las palabras
del presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden también sobre estos ataques
reaccionó después de que hubiera dicho
que Vladimir Putin calculó mal la
respuesta de Ucrania en en su intento de
Invasión a ese país y David después de
haber dicho también hace unas horas de
que no creía que al fin de cuentas a
Vladimir Putin iba a usar armas
nucleares en su país pues reaccionó
entonces a la salida de la Casa Blanca
en su viaje a Los Ángeles y dijo que era
simplemente brutal y que estaba por
encima de los límites lo que estaba
haciendo Vladimir Putin con estos
recientes ataques en Ucrania donde hasta
el momento se han calculado ya 20
muertos dijo el presidente también en
estas intercambios que ha tenido con los
medios de comunicación que no se quería
referir nuevamente a la respuesta de
Estados Unidos en caso de que Rusia y
Vladimir Putin decidieran usar armas
nucleares precisamente para no hablar
más las tensiones en cuanto a este tema
y La retórica en el en el amenaza
nuclear que ya habla de mimir Putin ha
usado de alguna manera como herramienta
de guerra al verse arrinconado como lo
muestran reportes de los avances
ucranianos en su territorio
el presidente francés Emmanuel macrón
también reaccionó a la escalada rusa
macrón aseguró que el mundo no quiere
una guerra mundial y que de hecho el
mundo está ayudando a Ucrania a resistir
en su suelo jamás ha atacar a Rusia
Vladimir Putin debe de tener esta guerra
y respetar la integridad territorial de
Ucrania expresó el presidente francés
y precisamente ante la escalada de la
ofensiva rusa la otan va a mandar nuevos
equipos de defensa aérea Ucrania de
hecho reforzar el apoyo a kiev ha sido
el punto central de la reunión de la
alianza atlántica de este día en
Bruselas a continuación les traemos los
detalles del equipamiento militar que
solicita Ucrania la otan
[Música]
armas terroríficas que descienden del
cielo a velocidades Aparentemente
imposibles estos drones suicidas y
misiles de cruceros son disparados en
masa desde barcos y aviones rusos
Moscú ha estado enviando una lluvia de
destrucción sobre Ucrania durante dos
días lo que ha llevado al presidente
bolodimir selenski a pedir ayuda urgente
a los países del g7
les pido que refuercen Nuestro esfuerzo
conjunto para ayudar financieramente a
crear un escudo aéreo para Ucrania
Ucrania pretende instalar la llamada
cúpula de hierro similar a los sistemas
de defensa antimisiles que existen en
Israel o alrededor de Washington DC la
capital estadounidense está protegida
por el Sistema Nacional avanzado de
misiles tierra aire o nasams para
Ucrania esta tecnología podría ser un
escudo crucial en 10 segundos el sistema
puede detectar misiles enemigos y
destruirlos en pleno vuelo creando en
efecto una burbuja de protección
el sistema nasams tiene una capacidad de
interceptación de hasta 150 kilómetros
el uso principal de ese sistema Sería
para la defensa de kiev y la defensa de
las principales ciudades en concreto
actualmente no podemos hacer una burbuja
100% impenetrable incluso con muchos
sistemas combinados de múltiples capas
en un solo lugar según el Ministerio de
defensa de Ucrania la mitad de los 84
misiles de crucero rusos fueron
interceptados el lunes como aquí
nos dé un soldado ucraniano utilizó un
misil disparado desde el hombro con gran
efecto para su defensa antiaérea kiev
despliega actualmente pequeños
lanzadores de misiles portátiles y
sistemas s-300 desarrollados por la
antigua Unión soviética El martes llegó
desde Alemania el primer sistema de
defensa antiaérea Iris más sofisticado
mientras Estados Unidos ha aprobado el
envío de al menos 8 baterías de sus
afamados nasams a Ucrania
en otras noticias en Irán continúan las
protestas desatadas por la muerte de
maxa bajo custodia de la policía de la
moral el 16 de septiembre ya son cuatro
semanas de manifestaciones en medio de
una represión mortal amam con los
detalles por cuarta semana consecutiva
de manifestaciones en Irán
sanandage la capital de la provincia de
curdistán iraní sigue siendo uno de los
escenarios del levantamiento contra el
gobierno la ciudad está sometida a una
represión y a un bloqueo que la deja
prácticamente aislada del resto del
mundo pero estas imágenes verificadas
por la agencia de noticias
dan una idea de la situación
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos expresaron su
preocupación
amnistía internacional está alarmada por
la represión de las protestas en
sanandage en la provincia del kurdistán
Irán culpa a los grupos de oposición
kurdos iraníes asentados
algunos son agentes del enemigo o si no
son agentes del enemigo entonces están
alineados con el enemigo con los mismos
objetivos salen a la calle la revuelta
en Irán comenzó el 16 de septiembre tras
la muerte de una mujer curda masa a
Minnie después de su detención por la
policía de la moral enterarán la
provincia del curtistan es una región
que históricamente se ha enfrentado a la
República islámica de Irán ahí los
habitantes mayoritariamente Sony es son
regularmente discriminados esta semana
por primera vez desde que comenzaron las
protestas los trabajadores del complejo
petroquímico y de la refinería de
azalubia en el sur de Irán lanzaron una
protesta en apoyo de los manifestantes
es poco común que una huelga de
trabajadores se realicen apoyo de una
protesta pública las huelgas fueron una
de las herramientas que llevaron a la
revolución de 1979 y a la caída del chat
de Irán
vamos a Francia porque el Sindicato de
trabajadores cgt afirmó que impugnará
ante la justicia la decisión del
gobierno de obligar a trabajadores en
huelga a volver a sus puestos de trabajo
en el depósito de la petrolera Epson
Mobile en normandía
el gobierno francés ha cumplido sus
amenazas los empleados en huelga de este
depósito de exxon Mobile tendrán que
volver al trabajo o enfrentarse a
sanciones penales los enfurece porque se
está violando nuestro derecho a la
huelga desde el principio a nuestro
movimiento ha sido Pacífico obviamente
nosotros cgt En cuanto tengamos estas
demandas presentaremos denuncias a
través de nuestros abogados por el
momento la obligación a trabajar no se
refiere a las actividades de la
refinerías y por tanto a la producción
de combustible
pero el objetivo es permitir el
transporte de la gasolina que ya está
almacenada allí 6 de las siete
refinerías seguían cerradas el miércoles
algunas desde hace más de dos semanas
está previsto que el gobierno realice
otra requisiciones en los próximos días
el impacto este conflicto social se ha
alargado y somos conscientes de ello Es
algo insoportable para demasiado
franceses
algunos de los cuales se les impide ir a
trabajar llevar a sus hijos al colegio
mientras las filas en las gasolineras se
alargan en toda Francia en algunos
departamentos los preceptos dan
prioridad a los vehículos de emergencia
y a los cuidadores una medida que no a
todo el mundo le gusta esta es la
tercera estación de servicio en la que
he estado Así que hemos estado luchando
desde esta mañana desde las 7 de la
mañana estoy en la calle ante la
probabilidad de que continúe la escasez
cada vez más sindicatos de las llamadas
profesiones esenciales exigen un acceso
prioritario
vamos a Venezuela donde los trabajadores
de rescate aseguran que no esperan
encontrar supervivientes entre los
escombros del deslizamiento de tierra
ocurrido el sábado en las tejerías hasta
el momento se registran más de 40
fallecidos
tras días de trabajo incansable Los
rescatistas no tienen más esperanzas
encontrar sobrevivientes pero debajo del
barro y las ramas ven el cuerpo de una
víctima
5 días después el derrumbe se han
encontrado más de 40 cuerpos pero mucha
gente sigue desaparecida para sus seres
queridos la espera es insoportable
cercanos míos míos y dos familiares
primos lejanos sabes cinco personas que
están desaparecidas Y todavía ni
siquiera aparecían en lista Quiero
comida yo creo que aparezca mi
familiares de verdad el domingo se
decretó luto nacional por parte de las
autoridades luego de hacerse presente
allí el lunes el mandatario venezolano
Nicolás Maduro dio una nueva valoración
en la televisión Estatal y todavía hay
un número importante desaparecido
56 desaparecidos
estamos llegando casi a un centenar de
víctimas fatales de
esta tragedia este desastre natural el
deslave se produjo el sábado Luego de
lluvias torrenciales en esta región del
centro Norte del país es el peor
desastre natural en Venezuela desde
principios del siglo una catástrofe
relacionada según los expertos al cambio
climático pero agravada por una
Urbanización descontrolada con viviendas
construidas en zonas de riesgo las
autoridades han habilitado alojamientos
de emergencia y han anunciado la
distribución de 300 toneladas y
alimentos
el 12 de octubre de 1492 Cristóbal Colón
llegó a América lo que desencadenó en la
colonización española del continente más
de 500 años después la fecha sigue
causando controversia por Cómo debe ser
conmemorada en Guatemala el movimiento
anti racista encabezado por mujeres
indígenas denuncia el persistente
racismo institucional en el país
nuestros corresponsales auror bayote y
Andrés Suárez nos traen la historia
vinieron de Ecuador México Colombia
Honduras 500 mujeres indígenas de todo
el continente se reunieron en Guatemala
para enfrentar juntas las políticas de
exclusión que sufren desde hace 230 años
y la celebración por la llegada de
Cristóbal Colón a américa no entró en la
agenda de la Cumbre parte de esa
política
institucionalizada de del racismo que
existe en nuestro país es querernos
decir de que el 12 de octubre es el día
que nos descubrieron que a partir del 12
de octubre empezó la civilización en
nuestros estados para nosotros el 12 de
octubre ha sido uno de los días más más
crueles más oscuros de nuestra historia
el país anfitrión cuenta con un 50% de
mallas garifunas shincas y
afrodescendientes y dentro de esos
pueblos la pobreza es 300% más fuerte
que en el resto de Guatemala pero la
mayor exclusión la vive en las mujeres
por vestir la ropa que las identifican
como indígenas
las que hemos venido luchando somos las
mujeres porque somos las víctimas de esa
discriminación por lo que encontraron en
el uso de sus trajes una manera de
resistir está todo el proceso de
colonización en Guatemala hace un
proceso de desingenización Y entonces
mucha gente se avergüenza o muchos
Perdieron el idioma la indumentaria
nosotros vemos en nuestros tejidos como
parte de nuestros territorios que hay
que defender en el municipio de Santiago
Zacatepec que es donde solo las abuelas
seguían Tejiendo ese arte retomó fuerza
Verónica es una de las nuevas alumnas a
punto de aprender a tejer los diseños
ancestrales nuestras abuelas y abuelos
lucharon día con día para que
prevalezcan nuestro tejido cada ahí lo
cada color representa la lucha Y el
esfuerzo sobre todo la historia de
nuestro pueblo
530 años después del día en que cambió
por completo la historia de sus
ancestros indígenas Estas mujeres aún
resisten el racismo a base de hilos y
memoria
sigan con nosotros
[Música]